[Music]
let's take a short break from the
monsters from kaijus and dragons and
travel back in time to the beginning of
this Century to a movie that was kind of
popular and hilarious this movie is
evolution which had American Pi Tiff
meister and others confronting an Ever
evolving alien maners that came down to
the planet and threatens to overturn the
entire biosphere of the Earth here in
this video we will take a look at the
genus life form that never stops
adapting and evolving a life form that
at the end of the movie transforms into
a gigantic creature that even dwarfs
Godzilla and the Titans and for a reason
that we will explain later it's
impervious to Godzilla's attacks if they
were ever in a crossover flick so let's
get to it so the genus life forms
Origins remain shrouded in mystery their
arrival on Earth marked by their
emergence from a porous meteorite these
microscopic blue unicellular organisms
quickly evolve into a diverse array of
multicellular life within an impact
crater mirroring an intricate ecosystem
reminiscent of earths during the ancient
past their life cycle is characterized
by an extraordinary capacity for Rapid
Evolution achieving in hours or days
what other life forms might take
centuries or even millions of years to
accomplish the genus exhibits a
biochemistry centered around nitrogen
instead of carbon boasting 10
fundamental bases in their DNA a St
contrast to Earth's carbon based life
forms which only have four renous bases
remarkably exposure to high temperatures
triggers an evolutionary overdrive
propelling them through complex
Transformations these genus life forms
reproduces asexually and their parasitic
nature just a life cycle that consumes
and ultimately obliterates infested
worlds sending out new colonies to
perpetuate the life cycle Across the
Universe this is a hyper aggressive form
of panspermia so as these aliens evolve
they transition from microscopic cells
to large larger more complex forms
forming a very intricate ecosystem in
the caves these multicellular life
includes analoges to familiar Earth
organisms like lyans worms and insects
they then continue to evolve becoming
animals that resemble ancient extinct
life forms one such vertebrae creature
escapes the impact crater evolving into
reptilians and then later melan forms as
seen with the dinosaur-like dragon and
the amphibian crocodile like creature
anyway initially confined to the caves
which has become the aliens ecosystem
some of these species evolve the ability
to adapt and survive in the oxygen rich
atmosphere of Earth therefore escalating
the danger that they POs to the entire
planet they also begin to evolve into
bluish primates with no noses this shows
that after a few more days the genus
aliens would then begin to have sentient
life forms and have the ability to
utilize technology and whatnot but then
their F but gradual evolutionary path
was rocked to the core and this
triggered the climax of their evolution
this occurred when the military in its
attempt to eradicate them through
explosive force through Napal instead
triggers an unforeseen evolutionary leap
that resulted in the amalgamation of all
the life forms into one into a colossal
Titanic amiibo super organism this giant
amoeba creature was hundreds or even
thousands of meters in size and was able
to cover an entire town beneath its body
and Shadow the main danger was realized
when this creature started to divide by
mitosis and then the theorized
propagation of such gigantic creatures
would wipe out Humanity in a matter of
months but thankfully the alien's
vulnerability was discovered as the
element called selenium akin to
arsenic's relationship to carbon a
poison this becomes the crucial
Discovery leading to the successful
containment and destruction of the
infestation by dozing the gigantic
monster with a truckload of selenium
derived from common household shampoo
therefore preventing an Extinction event
so here is a concise description and
timeline of all the genus life forms
that was seen in the movie so in the
beginning was an oo that came out of the
media this under go a rapid chemical
Evolution becoming the first unicellular
supercells which was observed under a
microscope these blue amiibo organisms
then evolve into multicellular alien
microbes and then spawning subsequent
life forms in just a few hours the next
step in their evolution is alien fungi
and flat worms which colonize the crater
with the ladder evolving into alien
amphibians that invades nearby pools
after a few days a rainforest ecosystem
emerges hosting diverse creatures like
the blue and black alien Crustaceans the
rainforest predators and the symmetrical
alien creature this shows a German
Evolution that would have otherwise
taken hundreds of millions of years in
just a few days or a couple of weeks
further Evolution leads to an insect
likee Alien Parasite that can invade the
human body and also into larger aquatic
reptilian aliens that began infesting
nearby pools and water sources there was
also the green frog like alien that
attempted to live outside the cavern
ecosystem and had some sort of a second
mouth beneath its mouth M but it failed
and was followed by the emergence of
formidable alien dragons which spawn an
offspring that was actually tolerant of
Earth's atmosphere uh anyway in the
caverns an alien ape evolves which
showed high levels of intelligence and
also aggression posing a significant
Potential Threat in the end we get the
alien fleshy Mass triggered by the
extreme heat of the Napal growing into
Cav tentacles and then rapidly evolving
into a gigantic amiibo metaorganism
resembling the original unicellular
forms this giant monster is bigger than
Godzilla and can rapidly heal and evolve
into other life forms just like its
microscopic version and given its
chemical propensity towards heat the
atomic breath of Godzilla would only
further its Evolution so like I said
this monster is impervious to the Gman
however on a side note the director's
commentary for the film reveals that the
intended ultimate life form emerging
through the climax was originally
conceptualized to surpass both primates
and humans as the ultimate antagonist
something akin to a highly intelligent
humanoid alien that would possess extra
sensory Powers however concerns arose
that this ultimate genus life form might
not possess sufficient size to evoke
Terror upon its emergence given the
evolutionary trajectory of the genus
life forms at that time as a result they
opted to replace it with the Colossal
amoeba for a more imposing and
frightening presence and yes so this is
the original and the last species of the
genus life form so even though the movie
was a Sci-Fi Action comedy its initial
plan was a story that had a very serious
tone and would have been a classic
Cosmic horror flick if given the green
light now if you like this video then
check this other one as well and do
check out our channel for other monster
content we might have things that you
haven't seen before like subscribe and
we'll see you in the next video take
care fam